Everything we've done so far, has
been to set up the rules of the game.
We define the network, and
the notion of a flow over it.
And we've justified some of
the simplifications that we've made.
Now we're going to turn to the task
of actually finding a maximum flow.
The search will be an incremental one.
We'll start with a sub-optimum flow,
and then we'll look for
a way to increase it.
>> Supposed that we are given
a particular flow over a network, and
we want to explore how
we might change it.
Perhaps we realize that
we can increase the flow,
by routing it through this link here,
instead of through these two.
And that would then allow us to
add more flow, through this path.
This is equivalent to adding
a flow that goes like this.
Notice that the flows through
the middle, cancel out.
By adding this flow to the original,
I get the desired result.
Alternatively, if we just wanted to
reroute the flow through the top link,
we could add a circular flow like this,
which would then reroute the flow.
In fact, all possible changes that
we might make to our original flow,
can be characterized as another flow,
but different rules apply.
Certainly, if we've used up some
of the capacity on an edge,
we can't use the full capacity
in the flow we're going to add.
We capture the rules for
the flow that we are allowed to add,
with the notion of
a residual flow network.
We start by defining the residual
capacity, for all pairs of vertices.
Let's consider a u,v edge.
If u,v is an edge in the original graph,
then the residual capacity
is the original capacity, minus whatever
flow we already sent across that edge.
For reverse edges, where not u,v but
v,u is the edge in the graph,
then we have a capacity equal to
the flow that we sent from v to u.
We can unsend this much flow.
Everywhere else,
the residual capacity is zero.
In the residual graph,
the edges are those u,v pairs for
which the capacity is positive.
Keeping the network sparse,
helps in the analysis.
In this example here, notice how
the direction of this edge is reversed.
There's no residual capacity
going forwards anymore.
That's all the new stuff.
But there is a residual
capacity going backwards,
since we can unsend the unit
of flow that we sent up here.
This edge here remains the same.
We can still send 1 unit
of flow along there.
This edge in the middle
gets interesting,
because we can either
send 1 unit of flow,
that would still leave us inside of
these capacity constraints here.
Or we can unsend the unit of
flow that we already sent.